in one of my earlier videos I talked
about how I went through a Sartre and
phase that began as an undergraduate and
then ran into graduate school and I went
through a number of different phases I'm
going to shoot some various videos on
those talking about why I was attracted
to those modes of thought what I want to
get out of them and eventually for most
of them why I left them behind even
though they still have an appreciation
for them and another philosopher has
been very important for me as as a
person although I disagree with him on
many different different things is
friedrich nietzsche and i would say that
i was a full blown Nietzschean at one
point it's a little bit hard to say that
anyone's truly a Nietzschean because
nature himself is you know sort of all
over the map with with his set of ideas
not all of them really harmonized that
well with each other and I think you
know there's a good case to be made that
that was in some respects deliberate on
his part he thinks that reality is
fundamentally contradictory and an
active the product of the will to power
playing itself out in many different
dimensions in many different ways
historically in that it's it's difficult
to attain anything like a purely
objective completely agreed upon
you know rationally justified
perspective in all respects so it's kind
of to be expected that different people
would make different things on in
Nietzsche so I'm not going to talk about
Nietzsche as Nietzsche if there is such
a thing and I'm not going to talk about
you know Heidegger's nature to lose his
nature or you know so-and-so's nature
except insofar as they they were
interesting to me and played played a
role for me so I first got introduced to
Nietzsche back when I was just getting
out of high school and it wasn't through
am I
high school studies I actually did have
a philosophy class in high school which
was not a particularly good philosophy
clique quite frankly very boring and
turned me off on what they were calling
philosophy but then I had a really great
philosophy class I'll do a video about
that with this guy mr. Lorenzo that I
learned a lot from without realizing
yeah and then I I started you know
frequenting used bookstores quite a bit
in part because I had friends who would
do that sort of thing and in part
because I love getting my hands on books
and just pouring through them and I'm
not sure exactly what it was that I got
my hands on it was some you know
selections book a Nietzsche and what I
found in there was was really heady and
I think what I was trying to do is was
make sense out of a lot of things at the
time I was in some respects as a lot of
adolescents and teenagers are profoundly
f50 and not really quite sure about how
to get out of and all sorts of romantic
notions about you know what I want to be
doing or
perfect you know job for me and you know
there's a whole mess of things that I
can talk about with that but I was
always searching for something I was
always searching for what we would call
something with metaphysical depth and I
found that in Nietzsche and not just
metaphysical depth but all of
metaphysics of personality and
metaphysics of human persons that doesn
CS is just an epiphenomenon of natural
events but sees us and the choices that
we make and the commitments that we
sorters our way through and our own
histories and our relationships as being
in some ways foundational and and I
found that in me Chia and I found
certain types of analyses in each of
that that seemed to make good sense to
me at the time and for quite a while as
a matter of fact there's some things
where I think nature really got things
quite right
even today so I got introduced to nature
in a very unsystematic way and I
actually remember this this kind of
funny thing that happened I got invited
to this this friend's party and I was
you know I was actually just working as
a grill cook and studying karate and
working out about three four hours a day
and you know hike hanging around with my
my burnout friends and sometimes you
know going to parties and you know
just you know living this kind of heavy
metal' roughy and kind of lifestyle
right and but I was reading a lot too at
the same time and some of my friends
were real readers some of them some of
them weren't so I got invited to this
this party it was for a guy who I had
sort of lost touch with it was his
birthday party I'd lost touch with them
a while back and so I went to his party
and there were there were a few people
that I knew because we went to different
high schools we were in the same middle
school together and then we cast what
different ways and there was a guy there
there were a lot of college types there
like you know there they were in their
freshman year of college because that's
what should have been my freshman year
of college but instead I was you know
studying karate and and working as a
grill cook and getting into you know
various sorts of fairly light trouble
and and and all that sort of stuff and
reading lots and lots of stuff that I
could get my hands on very vigorously
and so I'd read some Nietzsche and I was
really kind of interested in this stuff
and I the guy was a philosophy major and
he said you know that came up in
conversation he was driving me home from
the party because I couldn't get a ride
otherwise
I have to walk like you know six miles
or so so we started talking and then I I
mentioned that I was I was reading
Nietzsche and he got a very snooty
attitude with me you know how could you
possibly be understanding anything about
Nietzsche if you don't have a teacher
you can't just read this stuff on your
own but that's what I was doing you know
and just to give you sort of an idea of
what was going on I was reading each at
the same time as I was reading Eugene
O'Neill's plays and I was reading you
know the history of the Mongol Empire
and you know I'm sort of reading
whatever I felt like you know thinking
about at the time I never was
fascinating me so you know some of
nature's ideas kind of kind of stuck
with me this notion of the will to power
this notion of unmasking that that a lot
of times you know what seems to be going
on on the surface really isn't what's
going on you got to dig deeper and that
are our affects our emotions are
intimately connected with our pretense
to rationality that even when we're
completely rational
our emotions are integrated with that as
well that was there was something that I
thought was very very fruitful
Nietzsche's perspectivism was also
something that I was really interested
at that in the time that the fact that
you could take any standpoint and find
another standpoint to contra pose to it
and then start saying well which of
these is actually the correct one and
how would you decide between them that
was that was important for me and I
didn't do a very good job in conveying
it to this guy that I was talking abut
but I was I was thinking about these
things and then you know I go into the
army and I really didn't think about
Nietzsche much then it's too bad because
you know I was stationed in Germany so I
could have gotten my hands of Nietzsche
texts if I had to fight Ben smart but
you know my philosophical career is for
the most part this guy just sort of it's
almost like a picaresque novels
just wanders around into this and that
and this and that so in any case I then
encountered Nietzsche again when I was
in undergraduate and kept reading him
and reading him and you know Kierkegaard
Sartre Nietzsche Camus those were the
guys that I really enjoyed reading and
you know I looked for those four common
themes be between these guys and the
notion of commitment and that you
actually had to try things an experiment
and that you know don't don't
immediately assume that you know what
people are saying is really on the
surface is true that was part of what
attracted me to nature another thing
that really attracted me to nature was
his sort of unrelenting elitism and I'll
be quite honest with you I've kind of
gotten away from this in part by not by
abandoning a sense then look there's a
higher and you ought to aim for that
higher as best as you can
now there's a bunch of gradations I've
gotten away from you know just sort of
saying if you don't have the top
everything else is crap by seeing you
know the the progress that has to be
made and by learning how to be
empathetic and to appreciate you know
things and other levels and appreciate
where people are but one of the things
that really did attract me to Nietzsche
was his unrelenting elitism and his
insistence that democracy was nonsense
that this let's put it to the public to
decide what he said this was long with
Kierkegaard it was just silly that it
when it came to fundamental important
life questions you had to figure these
things out for yourself and you you
shouldn't leave them to other people's
sake answers or what they're comfortable
with or even the people who act like
they're progressive I remember people
saying things you know it was very
popular back
I was in college to say who gave you the
right to etc etc etc it was usually done
to try to shame somebody in the service
of being progressive and then I said
well who gave you the right to ask who
who you know what right anybody has I
mean you're just asserting yourself
basically you're acting like an
aggressor just like this guy over here
that you're criticizing so why don't you
act like a real aggressor take the mask
off and actually you know measure up to
here your you know your own desire there
why don't you just come right out and
say that you want things this way and
don't be passive-aggressive about it
later on I learned to see that was what
you know nature's calling reasons a
month but I was struggling with with all
these sorts of things with Nietzsche
there was a sense that there was a climb
that philosophy was this constant
ascesis this effort to try to rid
yourself of of preconceptions and the
debt riches of the past and what was not
really living but sort of parasitical on
your life and to experience and to come
to make your own judgments and there's a
paradox and involved with that of course
because if you're doing that because
Nietzsche told you to are you really
doing what Nietzsche is telling you to
not not exactly and there's also this
this sense of Nietzsche that look there
are some people that are just you know
spontaneously more energetic more
willing to you know push things we're
willing to try things more willing to
get in the fray and with those sort of
people don't try to put all sorts of
restrictions on them let them do what
they're going to do those are the strong
those are the the class that you know
will be the master you know perhaps even
the Huber mention of Superman or the
over man well you know when you read
Nietzsche of course and you're just
getting out of your teen years into your
20s and you're in as I was at that time
just amazing shape if you're working out
three four hours a day the various types
of training
and you already are kind of tough anyway
by the way that you you grew up and the
circumstances that you went through well
you're gonna you know you're gonna have
this natural tendency to if not seeing
yourself in the role of that person you
want to shoot for that and that's that's
part of what was going on I also love
the fact that Nietzsche was such a witty
and brilliant and incisive analyst of
other people's philosophy of literary
developments of political developments
you know the guy had something to say
about about all these different things
and I wasn't so concerned I think at
that time with whether they were really
true or right they were to what degree
they were I was more you know it was
sort of like putting on a suit or
putting on some sort of costume and let
you do something there was kind of a
dramatic role of being in each you know
I started getting more and more rigorous
in my study of Nietzsche you know I kind
of forced myself to try to read as much
as I could I have to admit that you know
when I was an undergraduate I didn't
find the Spoke Zarathustra particularly
interesting I was much more interested
in works like the you know the genealogy
of morals and the Wills of power and
the birth of tragedy things that had a
bit more they were a little bit less
narrative and a little bit more either
aphoristic or systemic you know where a
picture was being drawn I felt like I
don't need a narrative I can come up
with my own narrative and figure that I
want ideas I want explanations I want
you to tell me how things actually work
so I can start getting my hands dirty
with it I didn't realize how important
Nietzsche was to continental thought
until there's a whole story that I'll
tell about this some other time about
3/4 of the way through my undergraduate
I started actually reading some some
contemporary continental philosophy and
I saw how how neat chiyan themes were
playing out in people like Foucault in
Toulouse and Jared and art you know I
saw how I saw the uses they made of him
and the homage that they gave to him but
I people like that and so by the time
that I that I got out of undergraduate
and I had that year where I just worked
and it was mostly crap jobs it worked
and studied intensively and worked out
all also being all the more and worked
on my languages and then prepared for
going to Europe and then going to
graduate school I was getting more and
more into Anjaneya and so by the time
that I actually got to graduate school I
was still you know reading Sartre quite
a bit but I had shifted much more to
seeing things in a me chiyan way I found
that Nietzsche was a richer thicker than
then Sartre and one of the things that I
really loved about Nietzsche was his
attentiveness to language when I first
got to graduate school my intention was
to specialize in philosophy of language
in part because there was you know
learning languages and I was seeing
connections
things and I was really interested in
the you know how language fits in and
conditions the way in which we review
things and the way in which we act and
the things that we imagine possible for
ourselves and how it conditions culture
you know where words come from I was
interested in all these sorts of topics
I didn't realize that analytic
philosophy of language as opposed to the
continental philosophy of language was
not going to be actually dealing with
those those sorts of things too much at
least not in the ways that I was
particularly interested in well I'll
talk about that another another video
so anyway was Nietzsche you know being
able to to apply the things that he was
saying to interactions with other people
and you know to analyze the the the
conversations and the arguments and and
you know being able to make sense of
what was going on in graduate school
because Grant at least the graduate
school that I went to was very
aggressive between us graduate students
and even some of the professor's the the
engagements that we had and yet there
was always this sort of veneer of oh yes
we're just you know we're just doing
something academic we're being very you
know civil and nice to each other but
but the undercurrent was quite often all
this emotional stuff that was you know
kind of interesting to think about and
pay attention to and again my attitude
was he just tear the masks off you know
and I was getting that I was getting
that from from Nietzsche now what was
really interesting for me my first se
year in graduate school was I got an
office and I would hang out my office
late at night and you know work on stuff
and read and all that there was another
graduate student when I got to be good
friends with who was two years ahead of
me and he was also very interested in
media and we had when we started
comparing things he was also you know
much better school than that than I was
he'd gone to Penn State and
you know had professors who actually
like you know groomed you and took an
interest in your development and tried
to make sure that you actually knew what
was going on in contemporary philosophy
so he was really into Stanley Rosen's
understanding of each and Rosen had
certain themes that he would you know go
after time and time again much more
interested in the connection between
politics and philosophy than I was and I
was if anybody I would say was the
biggest influence on me at the time it
was probably Kaufmann his views on
Nietzsche but really you know I was my
view was always well let's just read
Nietzsche and not read so and so on
Nietzsche and then compare it to so and
so I need you let's say actually read
the guy himself and see what he has to
say so we would get into these big
arguments back and forth in the middle
of the night sometimes you know late and
sometimes actually into the early
morning in this this giant concrete
complex that was our office building
there's a again the whole story to be
told about that place as well was built
by a prison architect and had some quite
interesting design features so there
were a couple things that were really
good about that what was it was good to
see other people's perspectives on
Nietzsche the other thing was you know
when you have an interlocutor who who
knows their stuff and disagrees with you
you really got to go back to the text
and make sure you know what you're
talking about so that's that's what I
had to do and it turned out there were
sometimes things I I misread and didn't
get right and
with Nietzsche that's not too difficult
to do since he's a tricky writer and
sometimes over here that seemed to
contradict what he's saying over here
and if you're not paying close attention
you might miss it again through this
entire period I would say that the the
concepts I was most interested in were
you know the the ways in which the will
to power that everyone has within them
an aggressive will to dominate plays
itself out either aggressively or
passive aggressively and then about oh I
think I had already finished my masters
and I was beginning my ph.d coursework
they convinced even time and to teach a
class on meetcha usually he would teach
you know the German idealism stuff and
Hegel and Heidegger as well but there
was this clamor hey you know this guy is
really good with the German stuff let's
have him teach Nietzsche so he taught a
class on Nietzsche and he started out
with two losses Nietzsche book and the
way it worked was each one of us he had
to like you know read this text and then
and then present it to the class so
since you know my French was
particularly good and I already knew
some of the Nietzsche stuff and I'd
already read Toulouse in other contexts
and I kind of like to lose my sort of
just digested the whole book you know
within about a week and then presented
it to the class with commentary to and
how the translation over here is a
little bit different than
what you might expect from the French
and with Deleuze it was really quite
interesting because you know you could
see that for him Nietzsche was this
great liberating force that sort of tore
away French philosophy and he was very
concerned with you know making sure that
we never fell back into dialectics and
with the lose the key conception was
force which you know is closely
connected to will to power an active and
reactive forces and that's how he
interpreted in each at least man that
little book meet you and you know I read
other people's views on him as well and
then you know that was the semester of
intensive concentration on the whole
corpus of the works but in particular on
the genealogy of morals which I you know
went over to the library and got you
know the German copy and started digging
my way through it and it was it was
wonderful I really enjoyed it it was a
very heady time I loved Nietzsche not
only as a thinker but also as a stylist
his German is this is quite beautiful in
many respects except when he tries to
write poetry but but in you know when
he's writing prose he is just brilliant
and you know and he does what a lot of
other Germans do and makes up words by
compounds but they actually makes sense
and fit this works and he's
intentionally ambiguous and he exploits
the resources of every language that he
works with masterfully and so it was a
real treat to do that now what started
going on after that was I I would say
what ended up shifting me out of
Nietzsche was becoming dissatisfied with
where he was going
it did seem to me ultimately
to place you in the problematic of are
you going to just do this sort of hyper
aggressive route or are you going to you
know work with a sort of defamed
Nietzsche that a lot of people wanted to
put forth so that they could you know
have Nietzsche light and say that
somehow Nietzsche was a feminist or
Nietzsche was you know a progressive or
Nietzsche was you know not really
serious about this part and or were you
gonna you know take him seriously and
sort of see the whole world is
essentially a massive field of
aggression or passive aggression playing
itself out congealing itself into into
history I never liked that that trying
to defang him but on the other hand I
started to I started to think well you
know I'd read him and I think well
you're actually wrong about this thing
and it's not so much that he was wrong
it's that when Nietzsche had decided
about something like what say for
example Christianity Christianity just
pretty much as a whole for Nietzsche is
all is all just in a bunk and you know
Platonism for the masses and all that he
does have a few things we were you know
he says I'm not a few nice things about
Jesus and he also actually has a few
nice things to say about the church
mainly when the church works as a power
structure but I was I was finding myself
my way back to or maybe you know for the
first time into my my Catholic faith and
you know reading a lot of Catholic
authors and I'd read them and I'd be
like and you know if if Nietzsche were
actually right Thomas Aquinas couldn't
say anything intelligent like he is over
here or and some would have to be just
shocked full of reasons and love but
that doesn't appear to be the case so
Nietzsche must be missing out on
something and there were a lot more of
those moments and you know gradually
that they began
to unravel this this attachment that I
had to seeing things through nature and
then you know the the language stuff has
started to shift more into the study of
semiotic s-- and into some of the more
you know recent continental philosophy
discussions of that so nietzsche kind of
got a little bit left behind on those
things as well because in a lot of
respects when it comes to you know how
he plays with language he is he is sort
of an old-fashioned romantic you know
thinking about this the derivation of
words and what that means for us and
what it tells us something else that was
particularly important for me was
reading mock sailor
a mock sailor was a a phenomenologist
who for a long time as a catholic
actually ends up leaving the church
towards the end of his life and Schaller
was very impressed by nietzsche and he
incorporated a lot of Nietzsche's
insights into his his work and you might
say well how can he do that how can you
do that as a Christian you know well you
know you you integrate what's true in
somebody and you try to you know not
just like dust you know push under the
the dustbin or something like that
the stuff that doesn't work but you
gotta actually explain well why did you
know why didn't he see this why you know
why didn't this work and Schaller
Schaller did that with nature and had
some decent explanations for why
nietzsche went right and then why and
where nietzsche went wrong the concept
of ressentiment is particularly good and
and Schaller has an entire work devoted
to this concept of results of money
begins with nietzsche and then ii
questions well as nietzsche actually
getting it right about this and what are
the consequences if he doesn't and and
so you know it just sort of went on from
there I went from being what you might
call a true believer and
you know a person who was trying to
emulate Nietzsche and and make him
making my own and trying to think out
certain certain problematics that came
up with that like you know am I stuck in
rosante Monson and how active should I
be and how should I be active and if I'm
listening to Nietzsche I really you know
as free as I ought to be maybe I should
like throw the books away and so I went
from that to having a much more measured
less committed appreciation for for
Nietzsche and I would say that means
that I left my Nietzsche and fades
behind me I would say as well and this
is what I'll close on that I used
Nietzsche an awful lot as a excuse or as
a justifier for a lot of bad behavior of
my own pride a lot of selfish behavior a
lot of self-indulgent behavior a lot of
putting people down a lot of
deliberately seeking out conflicts and
being tendentious with people and you
know and I would say things and you
don't have to necessarily have Nietzsche
to do this people do this all the time
in a marketplace of ideas and you know
it's good to always you know confront
people which is nonsense really stupid
nonsense but you know I would say stuff
like that with the idea that well look
if you can't stand up to me you're weak
and you don't deserve to be heard so
shut up you know I'm gonna lay this out
and at that time I was I was very good
at very aggressive that demolishing
people in arguments so so Nietzsche was
kind of a natural fit for me but I found
that you know once I started to attain
some reflection on that I really didn't
like that that part of myself I didn't
like the tendencies that were being
encouraged with it I didn't like what it
would seem to be precluding
and the sort of damage that it was doing
to relationships the Nietzschean thinker
has to do a really you know tough
tightrope walk in order to maintain good
healthy relationships I think so for me
the Nietzschean phase was something that
I passed through I still very much love
to read Nietzsche I like to teach him I
like to talk about him I like to use
some of his concepts I think he's right
about about certain things I think that
he got some other things fundamentally
wrong and I actually feel that he might
have restricted himself in in certain
ways might have been reactive in certain
ways but in any case that's my
Nietzschean phase and I'll tell some
more stories about different phases that
went through and in in my philosophical
studies and career in some other videos